new coronavirus restrictions have come
into force here in germany as it
attempts to slow the spread of the
omicron variant with new year's eve fast
approaching the government is placing
tighter limits on public and private
celebrations it's also urging those
still unvaccinated to get the job just
before the new restrictions took effect
people protested in cities across the
country
hundreds of people demand to pass
tensions ran high on the streets of
tsitao in the eastern state of saxony on
monday night
just one of many protests organized
across the country against the
government's coronavirus restrictions
and kovin-19 vaccines
it was a tense but a peaceful protest
in the nearby town of bouzon police were
attacked with fireworks and butters as
they attempted to break up an
unauthorized protest
authorities reported at least 10
officers injured
in the capital berlin there is little
understanding of the violence that has
erupted and for those who still refuse
to get vaccinated
we all get every mandatory vaccine when
we go on holiday without questioning it
so what's happening now is ridiculous
i think it's not necessary to take to
the streets and attack police officers
to use violence you should do it
peacefully
we're all in the same boat so why do
some have to kick up a fuss
i don't know if it's the right way but
people probably don't know how else to
express themselves
almost a year to the day after the
vaccination campaign started berlin
mayor francesca gephai visited a kobe 19
intensive care unit she repeated the
government's plea to the quarter of the
population still unvaccinated in germany
lassen's isis
get vaccinated i can only say it again
and again
the people lying here in this hospital
many of them are probably thinking if
only i had done it perhaps then it would
have prevented this from happening
there are opponents to the vaccine and
the measures but over half of the
population support measures now in place
but officials are bracing themselves for
a new wave of infections with the more
transmissible omicron variant which
could overwhelm germany's critical
healthcare infrastructure
well joining us is hayotsib he's a
professor of epidemiology at the
university of bremen here in germany hi
welcome to dw now over a quarter of the
german population is still unvaccinated
so what actually can be done at this
stage to convince them to get the job
yeah this is a
difficult task it's not a homogeneous
group obviously there are some who will
still go for the job they will
need information they will need sort of
low barrier access to vaccination and
that will work but we also have a a
hardened group of people for whom it's
it's more of a wealth and charming thing
it's not really about vaccination it's
more about opposition in general and
those ones it's much harder to reach and
i'm afraid we won't reach them with what
is on offer now
right so it's going to be it's still a
tough job for authorities now germany
along with many other countries are
seeing
sharp rises in infections but at the
same time we're actually seeing
infections in countries like south
africa and denmark who experience their
um their waves a little bit earlier drop
quite quickly what does this data tell
us about omicron
yeah if these things come through as you
mentioned then that would be really nice
which would probably mean we have a
hard and
quick wave that runs through the
population if that was the case
especially with a vaccination
rate that we have here um and some
immunity due to previous
disease then this would also mean that
perhaps you know through january this
would already be on the decline again
which would be very good news for all
the you know hospitals and and people
expecting to be hit hard by the omicron
wave coming up now
all right so we're talking about the
omicron wave now what if there's another
spike and a rapid spread of say a new
variant what then
well this is always possible but i'm i'm
relatively optimistic this omicron is
really um
very infectious and in the and
i ream of virology i don't think there
are many other viruses that really have
this this kind of infectivity um as it
is now so maybe that side there's not
too much more to expect but you never
know we have experienced a few variants
so we need to be aware of new variants
but we are already gaining immunity
to some degree against all future
coronaviruses as we as we move along
all right so some some level of
positivity there cautious optimism now
are vaccinations boosters and of course
masks the future not just for germany
but also globally
well i would more generally say it's
immunity that's
what is on the on the agenda for
everyone and that can be achieved by uh
vaccination unfortunately many countries
vaccinations are not available as as
much as they here in germany so for us
yes it's vaccinations it's probably
being ready to distance once it is you
know continuously needed or again needed
in in and times of rises of peaks but
masks yeah i'm sure we will probably
need mask once in a while but not
permanently every time all the time with
us so i think we just need to be
prepared and better prepared than we've
been but overall i think
uh we are we are getting better i think
in dealing with wax with omicron and
other variants
okay hayoti professor of epidemiology
thank you for joining us on dw and all
the best in 2022.
thanks
germany's constitutional court has
ordered parliament to immediately issue
laws protecting people with disabilities
in pandemic-related triage situations
now triage is the process of
prioritizing patients for treatment for
example if hospitals are unable to cope
with demand for intensive care the case
was filed by a group of people with
disabilities and pre-existing conditions
they expressed fears they would be
denied treatment if the pandemic pushes
hospitals to their limits
well joining us for more is professor
peter dabrock he is the former chair of
the german ethics council and
specializes in the ethics of technical
and scientific interference with human
life hi professor dabrock and welcome to
the show now why did people with
disabilities feel they needed to go to
court to get a ruling on this
first thanks for having me uh they are
concerned that because of their
fear of disabilities they might be
um disadvantage
in case in in the case of shortage
of medical treatment this is the reason
why they went to cultural the
constitutional court and the
constitutional
court
came to the ruling
that
the
the legislator has immediately and
rapidly uh to change the legal
frame in order to protect
these people
right well then from an ethical point of
view um how can doctors make a choice of
who lives or who dies in in their
hospital
first of all it's fair to say that this
is one of the most challenging
situations for doctors at all
because of the
potential shortage of medical treatment
so they have to balance on the one hand
to meet the
legal requirements on the other hand
they have also to meet ethical criteria
uh as the prospect
of
surveillance uh sorry of survival
and on the other hand also
uh the basis basic dignity of each human
being and this is extremely difficult to
balance in this given uh catastrophic uh
situation and uh therefore uh we have to
look for this
balancing in order not uh to limit the
scope of action for uh for doctors and
on the other hand nevertheless uh to um
keep the frame of the constitutional
um frame and this is so extremely
difficult to manage
professor peter dabrock thank you for
joining us on dw